>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
LASTLY, LAST MONDAY, WE TOLD YOU
THE BITE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
BUSTER'S LARGEST INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING AGENCY, THE NSA, HAD
BEEN READING MY PRIVATE EMAILS.
EVEN SAYING THAT OUT LOUD IS
WEIRD, ONE OF THE SEGMENTS WE
NEVER THOUGHT WE WOULD DO EVER
BUT THE COUNTRY HAS CHANGED THAT
MUCH THAT FAST AND HONESTLY THE
WHOLE THING WAS KIND OF
SHOCKING.
THE GOVERNMENT WAS SPYING ON US?
COME ON.
THAT SEEMS CRAZY, BUT IT'S TRUE
AND NO ONE IN WASHINGTON
APPEARED TO BE SHOCKED IN THE
SLIGHTEST.
IN FACT, THE USUAL SHILLS, RIGHT
AFTER OUR SEGMENT HAD AN
EXPLANATION FOR.
IT NEVER HAPPENED AT ALL, THEY
SAID, JUST A CABLE NEWS SHOW
LYING FOR RATINGS OR THERE
MUST'VE BEEN A GOOD REASON IT
HAPPENED AND THEY BEGAN
FURIOUSLY MAKING EXCUSES FOR WHY
THE NSA DID IT.
A POWERFUL, HEAVILY-POLITICIZED
SPY AGENCY SURVEILLING
JOURNALISTS THAT ARE CRITICAL OF
THE REGIME?
NO PROBLEM, IT'S PERFECTLY
NORMAL.
JUST DON'T CALL IT SPYING.
IF IT'S NOT NORMAL AT ALL.
IT IS THIRD WORLD AND AS WE TOLD
YOU REPEATEDLY, IT DID HAPPEN.
NOW THAT HAS BEEN CONFIRMED.
YESTERDAY WE LEARNED THAT
SOURCES IN THESE SO-CALLED
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITIES TOLD AT
LEAST ONE REPORTER IN WASHINGTON
THAT WAS IN THOSE EMAILS, MY
EMAILS.
THERE WAS NOTHING SCANDALOUS IN
THERE, THANK GOD, WE ARE HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT.
LATE THIS SPRING I CONTACTED A
COUPLE OF PEOPLE I HELP --
THOUGHT COULD HELP GET AN
INTERVIEW WITH THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT BLACK REBOOT.
I TOLD NOBODY I WAS DOING THIS
OTHER THAN MY EXECUTIVE PRODUCER
JUSTIN.
I WASN'T EMBARRASSED ABOUT
TRYING TO INTERVIEW PUTIN.
IT'S ALWAYS NEWSWORTHY, I'M AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN, I CAN
INTERVIEW ANYONE I WANT, AND I
PLAN TO BUT STILL IN THIS CASE I
DECIDED TO KEEP IT QUIET.
I FIGURE THAT IN A KIND OF
PUBLICITY WOULD RATTLE THE
RUSSIANS AND MAKE THE INTERVIEW
LESS LIKELY TO HAPPEN, BUT THE
BIDEN DEMONSTRATION FOUND OUT
ANYWAY BY READING MY EMAILS.
I LEARNED FROM A WHISTLE-BLOWER
THAT THE NSA PLANNED TO LEAK THE
CONTENTS OF THOSE EMAILS TO
MEDIA OUTLETS.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
WELL, THE POINT, OF COURSE, WAS
TO PAINT ME AS A DISLOYAL
AMERICAN, A RUSSIAN OPERATIVE.
I'VE BEEN CALLED THAT BEFORE.
A STOOGE OF THE KREMLIN, A
TRADER DOING THE BIDDING OF A
FOREIGN ADVERSARY.
I'M THE ONLY PERSON -- I'M
HARDLY THE ONLY PERSON WHO'S
BEEN ACCUSED OF THIS, WE'VE SEEN
THIS MOVIE SEVERAL
TIMES NOW.
AT THE SAME MOMENT THE CHINESE
COMMONEST GOVERNMENT INCREASES
ITS ALREADY STUNNING LEVEL OF
CONTROL OVER THIS COUNTRY, OUR
LEADERS PRATTLE ON ABOUT THE
THREAT OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE'S AN EVILDOER, THEY TELL US,
A TOTALITARIAN DICTATOR.
VLADIMIR PUTIN DOES THINGS THAT
NO AMERICAN LEADER WOULD EVEN
CONSIDER.
HE RUNS DOMESTIC DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS.
HE LIES TO THE PUBLIC.
HE PUNISHES PEOPLE FOR OPPOSING
HIM OR FOR BELIEVING THE WRONG
THING.
HE EVEN USES INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES TO SPY ON HIS OWN
CITIZENS.
BEYOND THE PALE STUFF, SO NO
DECENT AMERICAN WOULD INTERVIEW
VLADIMIR PUTIN, AT LEAST NO
REPORTER FROM FOX NEWS.
THAT WAS THE POINT THEY WANTED
TO MAKE, THAT'S WHY THEY PLANNED
TO LEAK THE CONTENTS OF MY
EMAILS TO NEWS ORGANIZATIONS.
AND YESTERDAY, AS NOTED, WE
LEARNED THEY ACTUALLY DID IT.
EVEN NOW, SOME IN THE MEDIA ARE
CLAIMING THAT WE DESERVE THIS.
EMAILING WITH PEOPLE WHO KNOW
PUTIN, ARE YOU?
OF COURSE THE NSA IS WATCHING
YOU.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET.
BUT THAT'S HARDLY THE POINT.
BY LAW, THE NSA IS REQUIRED TO
KEEP SECRET THE IDENTITIES OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT UP IN ITS VAST DOMESTIC
SPYING OPERATION.
SO BY LAW, I SHOULD HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED INTERNALLY MERELY AS
A U.S. JOURNALIST OR AMERICAN
JOURNALIST, THAT'S THE LAW.
BUT THAT'S NOT HOW I WAS
IDENTIFIED, I WAS IDENTIFIED BY
NAME, I WAS UNMASKED.
PEOPLE IN THE BUILDING LEARNED
TO I WAS AND THEN MY NAME AND
THE CONTENTS OF MY EMAILS LEFT
THAT BUILDING AT THE NSA AND
WOUND UP WITH A NEWS
ORGANIZATION IN WASHINGTON.
THAT IS ILLEGAL.
IN FACT IT IS PRECISELY WHAT
THIS LAW WAS DESIGNED TO PREVENT
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE CANNOT HAVE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES USED AS INSTRUMENTS OF
POLITICAL CONTROL.
BOTH PARTIES USE TO AGREE ON
THAT, DEMOCRATS WERE ESPECIALLY
ADAMANT ON THE POINT, BUT NOT
ANYMORE.
SO THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
WE NEED TO FIND OUT HOW THIS
HAPPEN.
WHO DID IT, WHO ALLOWED IT?
PAUL WOULD KNOW THE ANSWER.
PAUL IS THE HIGHLY POLITICAL
DIRECTOR OF THE NSA.
PAUL WOULD HAVE BEEN REQUIRED
PERSONALLY TO APPROVE MY
UNMASKING.
PAUL SHOULD AXLEY WHO ASKED FOR
THAT I'M ASKING AND HE SHOULD DO
IT IMMEDIATELY.
APRIL HAYNES WOULD ALSO LIKELY
KNOW THE ANSWER, AND EVEN MORE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE.
SHE OVERSEES ALL OF IT.
SHE MAY HAVE APPROVED THE
UNMASKING AS WELL, SHOULD
CERTAINLY KNOW WHO ASKED FOR IT
AND WHO APPROVED IT.
THAT'S HER JOB TO KNOW.
SHE SHOULD RELEASE THAT
INFORMATION IMMEDIATELY TONIGHT
AND AS APRIL HAYNES DOES NOT
RELEASE THE INFORMATION, SHE
SHOULD BE FORCED TO RELEASE THAT
INFORMATION.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF POWER AS
A TV SHOW BUT WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP PUSHING FOR THAT BECAUSE IT
MATTERS NOT JUST US, BUT TO THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A DEMOCRACY IN A
PLACE WHERE UNACCOUNTABLE SPY
AGENCIES KEEP PEOPLE IN LINE BY
LICKING THE CONTENTS OF THEIR
EMAILS, DISCREDITING THEM WITH
THEIR OWN EMAILS WHICH THEY
THOUGHT WERE PRIVATE.
IT DOESN'T WORK IF YOU ALLOW
THAT.
AND WE SUSPECT CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS WILL ALSO DEMAND AN
ANSWER.
MANY HAVE FINALLY AWAKENED TO
THE FACT THAT THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES THEY HAVE BLINDLY
SUPPORTED FOR SO LONG ARE NOT IN
FACT THE